yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing with Rita we trade off what is
he doing with the slider we have had
that number of times even a tournament
chess I think black should be ok with
the counter play against d5 sometimes
they just give you the pawn maybe I
should have taken with the other I was
just like a five was maybe possible
tightening Bishop before which was not
really taken into account why he while I
was cooking hold even that Terrell I
could have taken on at seven at the end
but ok i'm not against a quick win once
in a while j-just did not mean white
have to probably play Queen d3 here and
cover d5 oops sorry after that it's a
bit with weird I don't think that I
thought maybe this sir I have two tix I
have this okay but yeah it just just a
big fat Centopani d5 yeah but this is
not bad here I lagi five years haha
Mookie eight I made my own I just
what's too tempted by but I'd threat d 5
is just easily winning and he's got 95
yep it would affirm that would have been
a problem now can I mean after you get
d5 gifted to you and so on I didn't pay
pay to close attention my bishop before
is a nice threat but even he i can take
this check okay he really believed me
him that's funny add that the engine
wants to do this threatening this and
here it's terrible wider now the
extremely superficial game after he
blundered t5 I was just playing far too
quickly and allowing all kinds of things
okay thanks for watching